[Music]
magic
both beautiful and powerful binds
together our long history
that common bond we share is the legacy
of hogwarts
[Applause]
now it is time to add your own story to
these hallowed walls
and quite possibly shape the future
of the wizarding world
every corridor every portrait
every stone in this castle tells the
story
witches and wizards who came before
here you will meet lifelong friends and
grow into your own magical abilities
in the classrooms of the world's most
talented professors
and while your journey begins at
hogwarts
brewing potions taming fantastic
beasts and mastery spells there is
a larger world beyond these walls
a world filled with dangers you can't
yet
imagine an ancient knowledge
long gone from this world
that strange and mysterious talent you
possess
may be the key to unlocking this
dormant power
your potential
is limitless
[Music]
but what form will it take
the journey ahead will reveal
what you stand for
[Music]
the choices you make now
will define the legacy of hogwarts
playstation